Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Monday morning podcast.
Just before Friday afternoon.
And
Yeah,
just checking in on you.
How's it going?
How's your week going?
Are you having a bad one?
What's the matter?
Huh?
Did they switch out the water bubbler?
Did they bring in a different one?
I think the water tasted better.
You know,
I like all waters.
I don't like Disani is those call and I don't like Evia Mel.
It tastes weird amount.
All those models on Dave.
A salary swear by it.
I think it takes awareness.
Um,
all right.
I am in the middle of,
I'm this fucking name was tour,
the tour that does in and me and Joe Barton.
Nick,
if I do say so myself,
we uh,
I'm doing this on a bump sitting on the fucking bus cause the goddamn room isn't
ready.
I just got shut down,
right?
I came in fucking trying to walk in like I was some sort of big shot,
like I could check in at one 30 and they were like,
I'm sorry sir.
Checking is it three?
Go Fuck Yourself.
And I was like,
but wait a minute,
I'm the dancing clown at the casino tonight.
I was hoping I could bring in my unicycle a little bit early,
sir.
Get the fuck out of our hotel.
We don't want to see you until three o'clock.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
I need to get some sort of Reuben Kincade some sort of,
I don't want to fucking tour manager.
It's just somebody else you have to talk to,
you know,
deal with this shit.
Why is he engine getting louder?
That'll fuck.
Can you hear it?
It's going,
it's going to be this hum in the background.
You didn't have to fucking deal with that.
I don't,
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
so me and Joe Barton,
nick where um,
we did Portland,
Sacramento,
Reno,
uh,
San something or rather the wine country.
Then we did San Jose and then we did Fresno and last night we did a Bakersfield
and a Joe Barden.
Nick left today on the tour.
He's a had to go to the airport.
He's flying to Pittsburgh cause him and Paul Versey is,
or doing an all in date in Pittsburgh,
which is why Joe is flying to Pittsburgh.
So if you guys are around,
it's the DV comedy festival.
Um,
some of my great friends in this business or at that radio station,
they did a lot for me over the years.
Uh,
Randy Bauman and all those guys.
Um,
and,
uh,
the fuck am I talking about?
He had to go check out this show.
If you get a chance,
sorry,
this humming in the background.
He's fucking driving me up the wall here.
So anyways,
I forgot to tell you guys this story last week.
So we're in Rito,
right fucking Reno.
And uh,
I told you,
I,
everybody knows a bunch of drunks.
There are a lot of drunks or whatever mixed in with a bunch of great people and
a,
so afterwards I'm whoring myself out,
right?
I'm whoring myself out,
I'm fucking signing the posters,
shaking hands,
kissing babies,
doing all that shit.
And this fucking dude reaches in.
He goes,
is it okay if I get a picture?
And it's just like,
yes,
I just fucking,
I'm taking them with everybody.
What I want.
Just going to say you can't have one.
Maybe it's just being polite,
but you know,
just get on with it.
You already know the cell phone's going to take for fucking ever.
I really missed disposable cameras.
That was just a little crank and then point shoot and it was done.
You know,
you press the fucking photo on the cell phone thing.
It takes like,
you know,
like nine hours and then also,
then they look at it,
they go,
hey,
get up blurry.
Let me do it again.
Now that isn't right.
Like can we also take landscape?
Do you mind if I was taking a selfie?
Can I take one with this pant fucking camera?
Even though I just got one with the other camera and I have the technology to
send it to that other camera,
can I do it with that camera?
So I'm dealing with all of that shit.
So this fucking guy comes up and he's like,
can I get a picture?
And I say,
yeah,
obviously,
you know,
I'm a fucking horse.
You can do whatever you want
or myself out here.
So he reaches into his fucking jacket and all of a sudden,
just this fucking sound of metal and plastic of fucking nine millimeter that he
had on him drops down onto the ground.
The security guy is like two feet awaits facing the guy who just dropped the
gun,
but he's on his iPhone texting or selecting something and the guy I just go,
I go,
dude,
what the fuck?
And he's like,
Oh shit.
Right.
We both said the same thing.
They both said both have that same time.
He picks it up and I'm like,
dude,
do you have a license to carry that thing?
And he goes,
yeah,
I'm in law enforcement.
And uh,
I was like,
all right,
and then you just sort of walked out and then I say to the security guy,
go,
I go,
dude,
did you just see that?
And he goes,
what?
I said,
that guy just fucking dropped a nine millimeter on the ground right in front of
you,
reaching to get his camera.
Just fell right down on the ground and the security guy goes up.
She's lucky.
I didn't see that.
Swear to God,
it was like a line from his set cup.
Oh,
he's lucky.
I didn't see that.
It's like toad,
it almost landed on your fucking foot.
You know,
you get so zoned out by these smart phones.
And then I'm thinking about myself like,
wait a minute,
Bill,
this guy,
you don't know him from Adam.
He reaches into his coat and dropped the gun.
How do you know he did?
It wasn't a reached in to point it at you.
You should have kicked it,
tipped him over and fucking as he bent down,
push them over and then picked it up or ran instead of being like,
Oh,
do you have a license for that?
Like I'm some sort of authority.
So it was just so rest of the night,
just go on like what a fucking moron I am.
And um,
this cop later told me,
he goes,
no,
you actually did the right thing.
You know,
he stayed calm,
you blah blah,
blah,
blah.
It's just like,
yeah,
I did the right thing cause staying calm.
And he did and he wasn't a psycho.
I Dunno,
whatever.
Uh,
now,
now I have to learn how to fucking do that.
What to do if,
if,
if somebody is nine millimeter falls in the fucking ground.
Bottom line is,
even though he was a cop,
he wasn't allowed to bring that in there on the casino property.
Cause I think it was a,
uh,
owned by a native Americans or something.
Maybe that's why I have no idea.
But he wasn't allowed to bring it in there.
So they,
uh,
they chased him down.
Um,
and that was,
that's my reno story or Bud,
my fucking radio story.
Janet Reno.
Um,
so anyways,
so bart,
nick left fucking blows a,
but lie had comes in.
So basically,
uh,
you know,
[inaudible] pitch in like six and two thirds,
we got a to run lady just walked a runner and a,
we went to the bullpen.
We're bringing in law ahead,
right?
He's got his relief pitcher bid and uh,
he's coming in and he's going to be finished in this out.
So,
uh,
the lovely Nia is riding along with me out to Vegas,
so we're having a good time.
Um,
it was funny,
man.
I do.
We just picked her up because we were coming back from uh,
you know,
Bakersfield,
which what a fucking great town that is and selves.
Fresno.
By the way,
Fresno is a great town.
That all those,
those goddamn shows had me so freaking out about Fresno.
They never talk anything good about Fresno.
But anytime you watch a first 48 or something about gangs are going to prison or
some shit,
you can't watch any of those for more than three minutes before they bring up
bring up Fresno,
you know,
always like Fresno,
California picking apples is usually a fun thing for the family but not in
Fresno.
Right.
And then they cut to some gang banger who's got like a Bandana on his head and
went over and I can see his eyes and they got his voice all muffled.
NEWCO forward.
We couldn't unhelpable dollar pool both to clear up.
And your lawyers are Bourbon.
Woodford usual
our lock Ross to putting a blown up too soon.
But the Dome
fucking full flow for fucking that.
The whole God damn thing is that.
And I would say what I feel about that,
but I don't need the fucking problems
anyways.
Anytime they show those gang bangers,
it's like,
do they ever have a good day?
Then ice cube write a song.
You know,
I had a good day,
I didn't even have to use my eight k,
you know,
Jesus Christ,
they're always fucking,
I mean,
you know,
I saw a thing one time where they said,
you know there's,
there's people in gangs in Los Angeles,
they're like three miles from the ocean and they never seen it because they
can't get out of the neighborhoods.
Like cause they got to go to some other gangs territory and the risk is too
high.
It's like dude,
just fucking drive through it.
Like eight in the morning,
nine in the morning,
everybody's asleep,
right.
You swung your fucking crack all night.
You know your banged a woman,
you fucking,
you know,
you gave you a bull bathy you're going to bed a couple of forties and a blunt
that's,
you're not up at eight 30 you drive through.
That's the time when the,
the decent people are getting up,
who are trying to get out of that fucking area.
It's at night.
You know,
when the second shift comes in,
those guys who he ended up seeing on those fucking channels,
your order three miles from the beach,
I'd never seen that shit that's even more distorted.
Her nerve or the Boudreaux,
no restraint.
That's more Batman.
I Dunno what the fuck it is.
That was having fun with that.
But then I go to Fresno,
right.
We're all,
I think it's just going to be pitfalls,
neck tattoos and I am going to get fucking just jumped,
you know?
And I went there and I ended up going to a Chili's restaurant.
I had a very nice waitress who actually had a quote from Walt Disney tattooed on
her arm,
you know,
don't be afraid to dream something,
something and probably something to antisemetic about the Jews.
She probably left that out.
And then it was Walt Disney,
right.
And then,
uh,
I ordered a Fisa,
mango chicken with some steamed Broccoli and rice and there was no incident.
You know,
I wasn't in there going,
wow,
this is comfortable.
And then a whole motorcycle gang came up.
Although,
you know,
it was funny,
it was during the show they had this sign like I actually when we were in Reno
we took a picture of that iconic sign in Reno that says the,
you know,
the biggest little town in America or something like that.
So Fresno has assigned like that too.
And uh,
I wanted to get a picture underneath that one.
Bakersfield has one.
These are like all old school towns before they built the five freeway that went
by all of that.
Like he had like,
you know,
you,
when he drove into a new town,
they had the name of the town.
They were all proud of it and shed.
I think it's really cool.
That's part of that,
you know,
just that shit that doesn't exist anymore.
Like if I was mayor of a town,
I would commission,
we've got to raise money.
We got to have one of those sites.
You know what I mean?
Some cute little quaint fucking welcome to this town.
Especially if people just drive through like farm,
you know,
all farming land and all of a sudden you come into town,
it's exciting when you see it.
It's really fucking cool.
Um,
for me anyways,
but I'm a fucking nerd.
So we got,
I'm on stage saying,
yeah,
me and Barden again,
when we got a picture that Reno sign and we want this,
this,
the Fresno show,
I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
we want to go down there and get a picture underneath whatever the Fresno
science says,
it's somebody in the crowd,
like 40 rows back,
just goes,
do not go down there.
And people only kind of laughed.
And I was like,
Jesus Christ,
he said it like,
like he was my dad,
you know,
and that was like his gun safe.
Do not go in,
you know,
don't waive this fucking thing around.
So there is obviously some truth it,
but uh,
you know,
where I was staying in Fresno,
it was really nice.
And,
uh,
I played this amazing theater.
Of course,
I wouldn't forget the name of the fucking thing I keep because it sounded too
close to like the Warner theater,
which all of them were called either that or the pantageous.
It used to be called a pantageous,
the pantageous theater.
And uh,
back in the day before there was the five,
it was,
they would do a bunch of movie premiers there.
So,
um,
okay.
You know,
they,
everybody from like John Wayne,
Humphry Bogart,
all of these people had gone there for movie.
It was a Vaudeville theater and then it turned into a movie house.
Okay.
Which is what all of these theaters,
like these older ones that you play,
that's like their history was a Vaudeville theater and then it became a movie
house.
And then somewhere in the sixties and seventies,
if it doesn't become a rock venue,
it becomes like a porno house.
And then there was discussion to tear it down and then somebody rich or somebody
gives a fuck about old stuff,
raises money to,
um,
you know,
uh,
refurbish the thing.
So this thing didn't become a or house.
So it became a rock house in which I found,
which was really cool,
was ACDC with bond.
Scott had played there and uh,
the owner was really cool and,
uh,
he offered to give us a,
like this,
this whole tour of it.
Of course,
I didn't have fucking time to do it.
Um,
but they had this amazing organ there that was between the crowd and the,
uh,
the people,
I guess they were going to tear it down or something.
Somebody bought it just because they wanted the organ or something like that.
I don't know.
It's a bunch of crazy stories in there.
But,
um,
so anyways,
downstairs,
everybody,
all those old school movie stars had signed the wall.
Oh,
the Warners theater.
W A r n o r s work performed.
And John Wayne,
how people got all of these old school stars had signed this wall throughout the
years.
It was priceless.
So when this guy who I have a deadly,
who bought the theater because he just wanted the Oregon or Oregon or something
like that,
like he wanted to fix the place up,
you know,
you know where the story's going,
right?
So he wants to get the place painted.
Any hires like a fucking relative to do it on the cheap and the guy or the lady,
whatever went down there,
it was a guy who's kidding,
who it was a fucking guy.
He goes down,
this is seventies were more even a lot out of the house at that point,
right?
So he fucking goes down there and he paints over the whole fucking thing.
So the guy showed me,
he goes behind this wall is,
uh,
is all,
is all the signatures,
and they're trying to figure out a way,
you know,
oh,
someone's like paint archeology to strip off that layer of paint and get down to
the signatures because they are underneath there.
And uh,
you know,
I'm totally into that shit.
So I told the guys,
hey,
you ever want to do a benefit?
You know,
I'll donate some money and I'll come up and do a show or something because,
uh,
I think that's cool as shit.
You know,
like there's a,
there's a house and the next town over,
um,
from where I live in somebody's during prohibition,
this old house had built this in the,
in the Cabana by the pool had just built a bar and I guess that person was
famous so they knew all these famous people and eat album all carved their names
into the bar and it still exists and it's like a historical thing.
So if you buy the house,
um,
you're not allowed to do anything to the bar.
I mean,
you can use the bar,
but you can't,
uh,
you know,
remove it,
destroyed or anything like that.
But like they did,
they have everybody,
like everybody from like Louis Armstrong to a James Cagney and all that,
fucking anybody who drank back then carved our names into the bar.
So I liked that shit.
You might think I'm a nerd,
do think I'm a Douche bag.
Uh,
but I'm into all of that type of shit.
You know,
I am,
I'm weird.
I like fucking old cars,
man.
And I want to get that Ford Galaxy.
I'm going to do that bucket right?
The fuck else am I going to do?
Um,
so anyways,
old freckles here,
me and Barton,
it killed it both onstage and off.
We went to the gym like every day I go to the gym every day it's just become pop
me life.
And if you don't,
well wait,
we really mean it.
Um,
I had done an hour of cardio every fucking day for the last seven days,
the last seven days.
Um,
and switching it up sometimes the ellipticals,
sometimes the fuck in a treadmill.
But I've been doing that.
I've been doing my pullups been doing my pushups and a old fatty cake.
Fatty cakes here is,
uh,
starting to come off,
man.
I got fucked up last year when I was in the writer's room doing the F is for
family,
which is coming out in December as he plugs away here.
Um,
I just got it,
you know,
I got into that and he's starting to write.
And when you sit in a writer's room all day,
there's nothing more exciting than fucking lunch.
You'd be on fucking excited other than the fact when you figure out how to make
the story work.
The only thing,
second to that is lunch and it's a very,
you know,
it's a photo finish and a,
I started off eating healthy and the next thing you know we had Frito Fridays
and then you know,
you know you're in a writer's room.
He started eating like a fucking truck driver.
So I put on that weight and that was October,
November,
and then the holidays came around and then the Rose Ball.
So that was completely fucked.
And then I,
then I stopped.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm going to work out,
I'm going to work out.
When I started singing the gym song and then I did the Australia fucking Asia
thing and of course I got to try every beer and fucking vegemite sandwich and
dumplings and all of that shit.
When I'm over there,
then I go to New York,
I run into [inaudible],
it's fucking over and it just,
it kept snowballing.
And then I started back up again march and I've just,
I've fucking had it,
went out of my voice in fucking had it,
man.
I've had it with myself.
I'm so fucking,
I was getting into the point
where when I sat down to put on my socks and my shoes,
my stomach was starting to be an ae.
I was noticing it,
you know,
and I was making those,
I'm putting socks on and I,
I'm,
I'm fucking in my first trimester noises.
You noticed.
Let's just like getting it over your toes.
I was just like,
really?
I'm going to be the breathing grunt and Groan a person.
I can't fucking have this.
So,
uh,
I dunno.
I was actually,
this is the first time I've ever done one of these,
these busts things with,
with Bartek and I was just like,
oh my God,
us to fucking animals on this thing.
Like what is going to happen?
We're going to come back like 20 pounds overweight.
And uh,
Bart Nick was coolest shit.
He's always cool as shit and he was just sliding.
And I was like,
hey man,
I'm going to go.
And I told him the first day,
I said,
I went to the gym.
He goes,
oh yeah.
I'll go with you tomorrow.
Then that was it.
And that became our routine.
We'd pull in,
we check in and be like,
God,
we're going downstairs and we'll be there.
I'm each you there in 15 minutes.
And uh,
it's just been fucking great.
So now I don't want to stop.
And that's what I was planning on doing when I went into the fucking hotel.
The lady wouldn't let,
she gave me the Heisman.
She gave me the fucking Heisman.
No,
no,
you can't check in.
Is that what you wanted to do?
What is it that you wanted to do?
Because I'm about ready to tell you that you can't do it.
What I'm going to say,
it's their fucking hotel.
So their rules just thought they'd be cool man.
Um,
so anyways,
last night was,
uh,
was Bakersfield,
which was really fucking cool man and played this great.
Another quick,
all these have just been these cool ass old theaters and I'm considering they've
told,
tore down most of the old ballparks at the pro level.
I think just about all of them other than Fenway in Wrigley.
I think that's it.
They're pretty much all gone.
And,
uh,
these old theaters kind of fill that void for me.
And um,
I had a great time last night with the crowd and it's cool,
man.
That's like a two hour drive away from me.
It's as cool theater that I can go up and go play.
And uh,
you know,
if I ever want to work out some shit for a special,
I can just jump in a car,
right?
Jump in my truck.
When I get that back,
when I get the fucking AC finally put in,
um,
crews up there be,
there'll be the shit.
But um,
apologies to some people who weren't able to make it to the show.
There was a,
uh,
there was a fire along the five freeway and it was in danger of jumping the
freeway and a,
for those of you who don't live out in this fucking hell hole,
basically what happens is the flames get so high and the wind is whipping around
and the uh,
you know,
all the,
what do you call that shit?
What do you call not ash?
Ambers,
whatever you call it,
they get blown across the highway and then they just light up the other side and
then you've got two sides are on fire.
I've actually driven down the highway and just watch it at an out of control
blaze.
But uh,
it's completely normal out here unless this was started by,
you know,
somebody throwing a cigarette butt out.
I have no idea.
But some people were coming up from la or from the other side of the mountains
there to,
uh,
to see the show and they weren't able to do it because there was a fire jumping
the highway.
Uh,
those are the times I asked myself,
why the fuck did I move out here?
I left the lush east coast trees,
lakes,
you know,
four seasons sort of with global warming now,
whatever the heating up the earth,
whatever the fuck you want to call it,
however it's happening,
relaxed Democrats and Republicans,
you fucking lunatics.
Um,
whatever it is,
it just kind of goes from like freezing cold to fucking hot as balls now.
There's really no spring and fall,
which kind of sucks.
It's like a week of it now.
Um,
so anyways,
let me do a little bit of a read here.
I'm going to try a little read,
you know.
Okay.
Uh,
hey,
you like making money?
Oh,
this is Uber.
Oh by the way,
[inaudible] Patty,
uh,
Patty,
the taxi drivers have had it with fucking Uber and they pose that they did like
this demonstration fucking hardcore like blocking the highways,
lighting tires on fire and shit.
Cause the sick of the Uber guys,
uh,
taken all of their work.
So,
um,
I dunno,
man for civilized is a Paris and Fred's is,
they definitely have a lot of that shit.
Like they have a lot of like American type shit going on.
You know,
it's unfortunate.
But anyways,
I'm glad that Shit didn't happen when we were over there.
My French,
I'm already starting to lose it.
So I went on dual lingo today and just did a couple of exercises.
Man.
I hope I don't fucking lose what I found that I had shut up bill.
Just read it.
Okay.
Uber,
everybody.
Hey,
you like making money,
right?
Here's a really cool opportunity that evidently I have to share with you.
Driving with Uber.
Uber's that populace smartphone APP that connects riders with drivers.
Um,
well this is all the lies here.
I take Uber a bunch.
No I don't.
I love them by the way.
I do love him.
I just don't have them on my phone cause I don't want some fucking,
I don't know,
something no on my fucking phone number and where I live,
I like the taxi drivers,
you know?
Oh my God,
it's loud.
Okay.
You know,
sticking your head out the window cause they've been driving for 16 hours.
But you guys love him and you like chatting with the different drivers.
Some of them have really interesting stories as to why they drive Uber.
Yeah.
Going through a fucking divorce.
They love being their own boss.
They earn great money.
It's easy to start a,
you just stop fucking doing that stupid ass phone.
I'm sorry I'm reading this on the phone here.
Um,
it's easy to start.
You just need a car or a license.
Driving with Uber is great for anyone who needs flexibility.
Parents,
this is a really way,
easy way to work around your family.
Schedule.
Unhappy married people.
This is a great way to avoid your partner.
All right.
If you're making way more money than they are and they're going to take you for
everything you got,
maybe you can ride it out with any luck.
They'll die of natural causes.
Students,
you could make extra money between classes.
Now's the prime time to cash in with Uber.
No more stripping.
Ladies,
you'll thank me for telling you how to get paid every week.
I could be getting into your car when you drive Uber.
I won't remember it cause I'll be handed a call to action.
You got a car and a license,
put them both to work and you can start earning serious life changing money
today.
Sign up to drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com that's drive with uber.com drive with uber.com.
Um,
I supposed to spell it out.
[inaudible] dot com sorry.
That is a great way to earn money.
You know what I mean?
I wonder if you can make enough money just to be a fulltime fucking Uber driver
and he just quit your job.
You job sucks.
Just drive around.
Poor bastards who got to go to work.
You know I used to be,
you know,
I'm living the good life is,
you could turn your fucking meter on whenever you want.
That's what I like about it.
Like what did you forget your wallet and you want to get a fucking cheese
sandwich?
She just got a fucking,
I'm available.
You know you drive somebody around once you have enough for a cheese sandwich.
She kicked him out.
But I thought you were going to take me in the hallway.
Faded Lady.
All right,
blue apron.
It's okay.
You can admit it.
The last thing anyone wants to do after work is wait in line at the grocery
store,
Schlep home and cook a complicated meal and and expensive.
Unhealthy takeout is hardly better.
Okay?
That's where the new service blue apron comes in.
You know I got a bone to pick with unhealthy takeout is fucking cheap.
That's why you go buy it right?
But it's bad for you.
It's expensive in the end,
right when they got to remove your fucking gallbladder.
A blue apron delivers farm fresh ingredients and step by step recipes to your
home,
allowing you to create healthy,
handcrafted meals at home without going to the grocery store.
That's pretty cool.
For less than $10 per meal.
What are they sending you?
An apple blue apron sends you fresh ingredients,
perfectly proportioned,
making,
cooking healthy,
happy meals.
Jesus bill already saw easy.
My,
I was already an easy someone,
Neil,
we you.
I was already calling easy meals.
Really easy and fun that no chips to the grocery store and no ways from unused
ingredients.
Plus you learn to cook with special specialty ingredients that normally are hard
to find.
Seems like a great way to lose weight.
To me,
blue apron is perfect for date night cooking with friends and they even offer
family plans with kid friendly ingredients so the whole family can eat well and
have fun preparing the meals together.
Each balanced meal is 500 700 calories per serving and so tasty.
You'd never know.
Cooking takes half an hour.
Shipping is flexible and free and the menus are always knew they won't send the
same meal twice through.
This is fucking great.
It's a great way to lose weight.
Then you get to eat this shit.
Then you just crush waters for the rest of the night.
You go to bed a little hungry for their first night and then you're good and
you're in.
You're in your routine.
They work around your schedule and dietary preferences and blue aprons,
expert source only experts source only the best seasonal ingredients for
incredible meals like buttermilk fried chicken.
Now how the hell is that?
Healthy with creamy slaw and biscuits?
Yeah,
buttermilk fried chicken with creamy slug biscuit sets.
Not fucking hell.
What are you going to KFC and a roasted white fish and plump tomatoes.
There you go.
Served on,
on top of Soba noodles,
whatever those are was sweet soy sauce,
sweet soy thoughts and tie.
Eggplant.
Yeah.
I used to dance at a gay club.
I went by sweet soy sauce.
I just got sick of it after a while.
It's too smoky.
Uh,
your cook.
Incredible meals and be blown away by the quality of freshness.
Blue Apron.
It's a better way to cook.
Check out this week's menu and get your first two meals for free by going to
blue apron.com/burp.
You are are my treat really.
The first two meals are on me when you go to blue apron.com/burr.
Yeah.
They just commit myself to them.
Um,
all right.
What do we got left to?
Oh,
what did we go?
What are we going all right,
it's 28 minutes in.
I do a half hour on these fuckers.
Uh Oh,
Tom Brady's got his big
appeal this week.
I think it's a mistake.
I think he shouldn't have said Shit and he would have been the martyr and people
would like them.
Um,
and anybody who has sympathy for him who isn't a patriots fan,
I think after the appeal,
especially if he wins and they knock off a couple of games,
it's a,
you know,
but you know what the other side of it is,
who gives a fuck whether people like you and not,
it's about what's right is right.
You can have this guy,
judge,
jury and executioner.
I don't know,
man.
I don't want to get,
get going on and all of that fucking thing.
Anyone who gives a shit.
Right?
What else are you gonna do?
What are you gonna talk about now?
I'm settling into the baseball vibe though.
Everybody.
I'm,
I've,
I've decided that I am going to,
uh,
I'm going to start watching some games.
It always takes me a couple of weeks.
So I'm just sad that hockey's over.
You know,
I even like the basketball and seeing the warriors winning for the first time
and forever was really cool.
So,
um,
I'm going to settle in to the base.
It's just,
it's not,
I love baseball.
I like it in October when you can go to a game and have on a jacket,
it's like this shit,
this shit is for like Tan people.
You know what I mean?
People would love the Sun.
I love the sun,
but it doesn't love me.
You know what I mean?
I go out there,
I turned red,
I get skin cancer,
they got to take taken scoops out of my fucking wrist or whatever the fuck's
going on and a so I can't do it.
Like if I go during the day,
I got to make sure like I'm sitting under some sort of overhang,
you know?
Or I go there with a beach umbrella,
which you can't do cause people behind you can't stay.
You can't see.
Right.
And then I'm in La so God knows I'll probably get stabbed or stomped or some
shit.
You know,
he didn't.
If the colors the same colors,
the Dodgers,
it's just how it works out here.
I don't understand it.
I don't pretend to understand it.
I don't know what it is.
So when,
anyways,
tonight,
San Wealth Man,
wealth Bingo casino in the inland Empire Pyre
buyer.
No,
no.
Do you don't do drove.
We will care if you were um,
all short occurred burger when I was four years old.
I'll straight up my grandmother.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm doing that tonight.
The act is fucking,
I'm having a great time with it.
And then the next two nights,
uh,
which should be Friday,
Saturday I'm at the Mirage casino.
Got To have a great time there.
I got a couple of buddies from my old high school days are going to come out,
excited to see them and then uh,
we're going to end it all down there in Tucson,
Arizona.
And then that's the freaking tour and it's 4th of July,
4th of July weekend,
right.
Api Birthday to United States of America.
Happy Birthday to the United States of America.
Dude,
dude,
dude.
Do you see they're going to put a broad on the fucking $10 bill.
You know,
we're the only country that doesn't have a woman on our money.
As far as I know.
We'll probably not an Iraqi.
They probably still have to sit down there with his angry fucking face.
It'd be real worst,
Huh?
Is Too fucking maniac kids.
They would probably be on the money.
Right,
and I don't mean like they're on point.
I mean they will literally on the money.
Oh Jesus.
So they're going to put a woman on there.
Everybody's running scared of the ladies.
Now you know,
nobody's going to tell them to pipe down.
You watch this,
they're going to ask for everything and everybody is going to give it to them
because if you don't,
then you're sexist.
Right?
I think of a woman is going to be on the $10 bill than women ought to be
printing those $10 bills.
All right?
You want to take Hamilton's face off?
The guy that my great,
great,
great fucking uncle shot to death,
that fucking punk ass bitch talk at all his shit and he tried to shoot my
fucking great,
great,
great fucking uncle and his gun went off.
Then all of a sudden get out.
He wants to,
he wants to do over.
Fuck you hammy.
It's over.
Bam.
Right?
Then all of a sudden Aaron Burns the bad guy.
Now he's the fucking bad guy.
I think it's very fitting that some fucking broad is going to take his spot on
the money.
You know they actually want to be on the 20 because they say that's what comes
out of the ATM.
Cause you know,
no matter what you give them,
they always want more.
Right?
So there you go.
Be on the fucking torn.
And they were saying,
cause Andrew Jackson was a horrible man.
You know what I mean?
It's like well why don't you look up the rest of them?
They're all kinds of horrible considering this country began with genocides.
You fucking idiot.
So I've been doing a bit about this.
Like if we're going to replace a horrible man on the $20 bill or the $10 bill
with a guys,
uh,
with a woman,
then it should be a horrible woman.
Cause I don't like what that says then.
Cause if you're going to fucking have nothing but horror other than Lincoln,
right?
Maybe even then he kind of looks like a hipster,
doesn't eat with these stupid beard without the mustache.
We get it.
You're weird.
You got a personality.
He's top hat.
He dress like a hipster.
You know they're all dressing like that now.
Like they fucking,
they had old Abe's ear.
I don't want,
I'm talking about.
So anyways,
they're going to be on,
on,
on that money and uh,
I don't give a fuck.
I don't understand why it's even a God damn deal.
You don't have to,
you don't want to.
I think is fucked up is the queen of England is still on so many [inaudible]
she's on like the Australian money.
I think Canada's money.
I've been to a bunch of countries where her dumb faces there and they know they
only really even do anything anymore down there.
Why don't they just take her off,
put on Margaret Thatcher.
I always hated that name.
Margaret Thatcher.
Jesus Christ.
How Willie was her Bush.
All right,
sorry.
That is the podcast,
by the way,
if you want to hear one of the fucking great podcast of all time and if you are
a stand standup fan,
one of my big regrets as a comedian is I never got to meet the legend.
That was John Fox.
John Fox was the ultimate road dog comedian.
He was every single stereotype of a comic and I mean all of that in the,
in in the greatest way.
And he had every story,
you know what I mean?
Like when they,
when they go to do a movie about standup comics,
like you got to have a John Fox in there and uh,
Tom Rhodes interviewed him,
just Google Tom Rhodes,
John Fox,
j o h n Fox and a podcast and have a listen and just listen to them talk and
listen to them laugh and listen to his stories.
Like he is as much a comedian as Keith Richards is a guitarist.
Like you have a look at Keith's fucking fingers.
Like if he had,
even if you didn't know who the fuck he was,
you would look at that and be like,
that guy plays guitar.
Okay plays guitar and he smoked cigarettes.
And if you listen to John Fox,
I'm telling you,
you,
you can hear all the places that he's been in and Tom gave a great interview
and,
uh,
I,
let's do it by myself.
I was blown away by it.
And then I,
uh,
I had me and Bart Nick or listening to it last night on the bus,
just laughing our asses off,
uh,
relating to some of the stories.
And then the rest of the story is just sitting there with your jaw on the
ground.
Um,
he is the,
he's the real deal and it kills me that I never got to just fucking hang out
with them and listen to some stories because he,
I dunno,
I don't know that there was anyone like him.
So anyways,
there,
that's the podcast.
You guys have a great weekend.
You conch and I'll talk to you on Monday.
All right.
And now here's a little bit of throwback Monday morning podcast from a day gone
by no.
Or,
or do good care of your hair as you could draw the pall care.
Yes.
Hey baby,
turning back.
Can I go into this pizza parlor?
You know,
I ordered a slice of pizza and I go out with it.
That coke,
coke,
coke from Mexico where they have the real sugar.
Oh yeah,
they have real sugar.
What do we have?
Five?
We have the fake sugar here.
Yeah,
the Mexican coke is better.
You know one of those Nafta moments like how the fuck,
okay.
Doesn't the United States of America have the best fucking Coca Cola?
That's our shit.
Okay.
How does Mexico have better Coca Cola than us?
I don't.
I don't get it.
How did the fuck,
how did that happen?
Is that console slick willy signed NAFTA?
Is that what he did?
Is that,
is that the part of his soul that he had to sell so they,
they,
they'd put him in office.
Fucking assholes.
They're all the God damn saying.
They're all a bunch of sellouts Democrat or Republican fucking idiots walking
around with signs watching CNN or Fox News.
You're morons.
You're going to get the same result.
They're going to Democrat or Republican that dropping to their knees and they're
blowing the bankers.
All right,
so enough with your fucking debates.
So anyway,
so I go in there and I go,
let me get a slice of pizza and I'll get evidently the important Coca Cola,
you guys have fucked up.
That is,
that's like at the Guinness tasted better over here than it did in Ireland.
That doesn't make any fucking sense whatsoever.
So anyway,
so I walk in there and this stupid ass song,
I didn't know the name of the song.
I just know I've heard it in elevators.
I've seen it on television.
I've seen it in commercials.
I hear it in malls.
I can't get away from this fucking song.
This song sucks.
I unbelievably on so many fucking levels.
Everywhere I go,
this stupid ass song is playing.
I don't know if you guys are familiar with this.
There's no way to eat.
You haven't heard this song.
Here it is.
Okay.
You know the song scape is gap adapt with dual,
but dad buggy.
We do.
Bye Bye.
Charged to preach you too hot.
Yeah.
Shut the fuck up.
You fucking Douche with a Ukulele.
Oh Jesus Christ that Steph.
See Animal House moment.
John Belushi should be walking down a flight of stairs to that guy and then
smashing the shit out of his guitar.
Except this time he shouldn't say sorry.
He should smash it over.
This guy's fucking head.
Sorry.
I'm going a bit of a mode.
Why is that songs so popular?
You know why it is because that song moves through your head like fucking air.
Alright comes in one year and it goes right out the other and you are left with
zero thoughts.
Listen to this fucking thing.
You tell me.
Okay.
If you're actually trying to fucking live any sort of a meaningful life,
how in the fuck can you do it when they shit like this in the background.
Cool.
Done.
Jackie.
I,
I'm in fucking sandals and no one gives a shit.
Um,
I'm yours.
That's one for the vaginas.
You know,
download that right to your fucking Twat.
He wasn't even trying to make guys fance.
There's a smart man right there.
I bet he's worth,
he's worth this day and age in the music business.
Yeah,
but he,
but he got that bad
do if you'll have me tied to a chair while waiting for a delayed flight playing
that music.
That is my Guantanamo Bay right there.
I'd rather be fucking waterboarded then listen Elia,
who's getting,
no,
I don't want to slowly drawn for an hour,
but you know,
I would consider it
[inaudible]
mmm.
That's like the,
that's like the fucking,
uh,
the,
these,
these black tubes who was standing on the corner of Minneapolis,
uh,
you know,
those guys who scream about religion,
do they ever have like the levels of their pa a juxtapose correctly?
They always talking way too loud.
Yeah.
Or the so called war.
Who'd be Tom to talk about some shit.
So cool.
What are the devil?
Yeah,
you have a mother fucker.
And it's just so Paul what,
and you know what's funny is half to white people who walk by,
they probably think that they're making that face like disapproving of the
message rather than the level of,
it's just towed.
Get a new fucking PA,
get a fucking God damn,
uh,
whatever the fuck he call a person who knows how to run the board,
make it a clean sound.
Okay.
And send it beam line.
Excuse me sir.
Not trying to interrupt your hate.
Um,
I just,
it's really difficult to understand what it is I'm supposed to be offended by
what?
I can't understand what it is just saying.
Um,
journal rose actually said to the Guy Jesus was white and one of his,
his,
uh,
a terminator x guys actually laughed.
And then another guy stared at him and then he went right back to the,
uh,
fuck white people face.
Once again.
Another classic example why I stay away from organized religion because it leads
you to that.
You know,
Jesus loves everybody,
but he's our color and he loves us best,
but he loves everyone.
So what this whole call,
what be throwing up these motherfuckers,
these motherfuckers,
that shit can't have black quarterback.
What the fuck is that?
So cool.
What ma'am?
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
I'm sure that bothered a lot of your ears.
I apologize for that.
But that's literally what the fuck it sounded like.
MMM.
I would like to do that on a street corner.
Have a really bad pa like that and just be saying a bunch of fucking reverse
racist shit about white people.
Okay.
I wonder if anybody would get it.
The amount of people
wouldn't.
That was what would make it really hilarious.
But he's like,
[inaudible] the fuck is my newspaper
for here.
This is at the risk of burning some potential material.
This is something you can look forward to watching me go off road in the future.
On stage.
All right,
hang on a second.
I got blow my God damn nose again.
Hold on.
Just go eat a pastry.
Fuck.
Wow.
Yeah,
we go.
You had to get it out of the mustache.
Anyways,
so everybody saw what happened on a swatch Schwartzenegger this week,
right?
So Time magazine has a,
uh,
has an article out there says sex lies arrogance.
What makes powerful men act like pigs?
Okay,
so I look at the,
who wrote it?
It's written by Old Lady.
How fucking funny is that?
Sex lies.
Arrogance.
What Po?
What makes powerful men act like pigs.
A woman is going to tell the world why guys act the way they act.
Do you realize how fucked up?
Okay,
at what point are men going to make a fucking stand here with this?
I don't want to come off like a chauvinist pig here and you just giving away.
Every guy should have wrote this article.
He could've had so much more fucking insight.
What the fuck does a woman know?
She doesn't know and the whole thing,
it's just the whole thing is written.
Bye.
In the,
in the female's point of view,
which is the only thing you understand is being that woman who got cheated on.
Yeah,
so there's this woman's scorn vibe under the whole article,
but there's no information in here.
I learned nothing.
I was reading it.
I learned nothing as a guy and she's fucking wrong on most of her points.
One of the great things they like to say is that
men of power,
the reason why they cheat is because they feel entitled.
They feel they're entitled.
I'm not going to burn the bit,
but that is,
that's not even true.
And what kills me is some fucking broad like this Nancy Gibbs.
What?
Sit there and argue with me
being a lady,
a lady.
Do you understand what you're doing there?
You're basically telling me that you know how my brain works better than I do.
I was watching her and the reason why I bought this fucking article cause I was,
I was watching it on television.
I saw the art and the obviously I like,
I'll fucking magnet.
I'm drawn to this.
I'm like,
oh I like this topic.
I want to hear what about this?
And then Nancy Gibbs comes on and she's talking to a guy
and he's going,
really?
Oh is that was it was.
I was okay.
Like
it's that shadow.
It's fucking terrific.
That would be like me.
Like here's something for you.
Here's his like,
like women,
you never get to know what it's like to have a dick.
All right,
so stop it.
Stop trying to write articles.
Try,
stop trying to act like you were in our heads.
And you know what we're thinking.
You don't,
you're always going to be observed.
You gotta be an observer.
You sitting on the grassy knoll what to do?
Where do the shots come from?
You?
No fucking idea.
You just coming up with your theories,
the nerve or you to get to cover a fucking Time magazine with this horse.
Shit.
Just a bunch of horse shit.
They got one over there.
Listen to this shit.
Uh,
the turning points,
this is from another lane.
They had two people write about this shit.
Elaine,
I can't even read a fucking last name.
C O Lino,
whatever.
Frances having it's Anita Hill moment.
When the law professor testified before the Senate committee in 1991 that a
former boss,
Clarence Thomas,
had sexually harassed her.
He denied everything and was elevated to the Supreme Court.
Notice how the fucking angry cunt leaves out the fact that he was acquitted.
The guy was acquitted.
Okay.
She makes it seem like he was accused of that stuff and because of that he
would,
because of that attention,
he was elevated to the Supreme Court.
But anyways,
hearings where attorney but hearings were terming point.
Women suddenly said that the mad men style of behavior they had been putting up
with at work for so long,
the leering,
the inappropriate touching,
the sexual banter was not acceptable.
Do you understand that?
She's not talking about the 1960s there.
She's talking about 1991.
I'm not saying that that shit wasn't happening,
but you know,
I was in the workforce.
They're all right.
People weren't walking around going,
hey,
touch grabbing people's asses at work in 98919901991 they weren't,
I mean,
generally speaking warrant,
but this lady just fucking goes the mad men style,
which is from the 1960s Madison Avenue.
Hey Sweetie,
go make me a fucking sandwich.
That error,
completely ignoring all the bullshit that happened in the late sixties,
seventies,
right through the fucking eighties and the 80s.
They would talk about women wearing their fucking little power suits and power
ties and all that fucking horse shit.
This is all just one of these classic things where you just,
you just,
you have your angle and then you just,
you just write the whole fucking article.
It's complete horse shit.
Um,
what the hell is the quote in here?
I wanted to read.
I don't even know.
All right,
let me tell you something Nancy,
let me tell you something Elaine.
Those guys don't do that shit cause they feel entitled.
They don't.
All right,
they don't.
And if you want to know why come out to a comedy club cause I'm not burning the
fucking material out.
Talk about it a little bit.
I'll talk about real quick.
Alright.
What it is is women don't understand what it's like
to have a dick.
They just don't get it.
Okay?
The fucking thing tells us what to do.
You know,
and right now they're rolling their eyes because they don't understand the sex
drive that we have.
How could they,
they got a VAD.
All right.
And the is,
there's no information out there to help people to help guys out.
Nothing.
All guys get,
there's no information about being a guy in general.
Hey,
keep it in your pants.
That's the sexual advice we get.
That's what we get.
Fucker,
you got cosmo.
There's reams of shit talking about all the folds in your vagina.
Every goddamn month we get,
Hey,
keep it in your pants.
That's the kind of advice guys get.
You go to jail.
Hey,
don't drop the soap.
That's it.
That's all you get.
We get a little fucking four sentences and that's how we're supposed to fucking
navigate through life.
So you're pulling with a Dick.
He got this ridiculous fucking sex drive.
The only thing that fucking keeps it in check is the fact that women won't fuck
you.
You got to figure out,
you've got to talk them into it.
You go through dry spells.
That's the only thing that prevents the guy from fucking 24 hours a day is other
women making it difficult for us to get laid.
But then what happens is when you become an a position of power,
these cunts flip the fucking table and will suck your Dick under your fucking
God damn desk while your wife's sits across from you.
So now the governor has taken off.
You've never had to control your sexual urges because it was always done for
you.
You like a spoiled kid.
Now you fucking famous.
She got all these broads coming at you.
You don't know what to do
because you never really noticed how much you've been been led around by a Dick.
Now I'm not saying every powerful guy out there is an angel.
There's not this definitely some pigs out there.
There's definitely some guys out there who do feel entitled.
But to just paint it with that broad fucking stroke of a brush and have a
fucking woman sitting there telling me it's you.
You don't know what you talking about lady.
All right.
Okay.
If I just fucking blows my mind blows my fucking mind that they,
they put two people on this assignment and they were both women.
Was that some political correct fucking thing?
Cause they were worried that guys,
we're going to say what the fuck I'm saying that basically their husbands would
be out fucking everything that moved if women wanted to fuck the way we want it
to.
Okay.
I don't know.
And not to mention most people can handle power and that includes broads.
Okay.
So you get some guy in a powerful position is ego's already going to go through
the fucking roof and then you combine that with the fact that basically half of
the free world will now fuck him and he's supposed to somehow rein that in and
is only piece of advice is keep it in your pants.
You know?
I mean I dunno
they I that it's really embarrassing the Time magazine with this fucking
superficial that they just basically,
I mean it was like psych 101
how they broke it down
even though shit on on a Arnold Schwarzenegger about how he,
he likes fucking around with girls that aren't beautiful.
You know
they said it was cause he was intimidated by beautiful women and
Blahblahblahblahblah see they're women,
they don't,
they don't get the difference between hooking up with a hottie and hooking up
with the plain Jane girl who's going to try harder.
Okay.
As opposed to the fucking chick who's,
who's got 0% body fat and just thinks she's God's got damn gift.
You've seen that,
right?
You go to a titty bar?
The hottest one there does,
she tries hard is that fucking one in the middle?
She doesn't,
and after awhile,
you know what?
You start looking at those hotties going,
They're fucking more trouble than they're worth.
All right,
I wiped my dick sucked to completion.
Who am I going with?
Okay.
The supermodel looking chick or the chick who's just happy to be there.
Okay?
Fucking morons.
I got out of [inaudible].